this is a non-stop day of goodies of all
kinds of fandom entertain guys we are
going to watch today dwayne zilrock
johnson has dropped the black adam
official trailer call corey at 5 45 in
the morning like hey man working on
obi-wan but i think this is dwayne
johnson black adam movies coming the
trailers coming in like 15 minutes man
he just showed up here so thank you
court for being here he knows the black
adam comics really well wouldn't want to
do this without him guys thank you so
much for being here please leave a like
if you can this video today is sponsored
by storyblocks um partnering up with
them has been absolutely wonderful a lot
of people say this you know supporting
them supports the channel and it's just
a common phrase but it really does
because we've been hiring a lot more
people to help out around with the
channel lately
example a and all that kind of
partnering goes to help partner with
people like him so thank you sir blocks
more on them after the trailer and of
course stick around for uh koi's
thoughts after because he's going to
have a lot to say because he's coy even
when he's tired koi has a lot of
thoughts corey thoughts
[Music]
black adam
what have your powers ever given to you
i was a slave until i died
wow i was reborn a god
my son sacrificed his life to save me
yours look a little pointer
now
i kneel before no one
[Laughter]
in this
[Music]
heroes don't kill people
well i do
[Laughter]
my vision has shown me the future
you have two choices
you can be the destroyer of this one
god damn
that's up to you
[Laughter]
behind you
whoa did he just catch a rocket
[Music]
[Music]
river my goodness jay-z at the end not
mad at it that was epic i feel like
that moment with the planes was kind of
a jab at uh iron man to show that he is
not the hero where man were like let me
hang on the planes and he was like the
[ __ ] this yeah yeah also the doctor
mirroring doctor strange parallels
there's gonna be a lot of interesting
comments here because technically jsa is
the first superhero team ever the
justice society of america yes the
justice side of america from the 1940s
uh but they're the first team so i think
there's gonna be a lot of interesting
conversation about like what's
referencing what and what's referencing
the comic books this is what's like
popular in the world and also from the
looks of this i mean the rock's been
wanting to make this for 11 years this
is like his deadpool to ryan reynolds
it's a long run together yeah and as
such i do think the script has improved
and things have evolved so the movie
that he wanted to make can now exist
because of technology but it's
interesting where we don't have a
superman really right now in the dc
universe so we have this anti-hero that
has a lot of superman parallels so i
actually get more of like a darker
alternate universe earth 2 superman vibe
than necessarily even like a shazam
spin-off obviously this ties into the
shazami in that whole world i think
shazam 2 and this are going to come
together for a third thing but this gave
me a lot of superman vibes personally
wow sounds like that the journey dwayne
johnson has had along the way is
quite a lot of blocks he's had to
overcome uh it's called the story story
guys that reminds me of something what's
that john this thing
thank you to storyblocks for sponsoring
this video being the cinematic artisans
we obviously are we are always in search
of ways to make our videos look better
faster and most of all for cheap cheap
is good and if you're a content creator
or filmmaker or anything in between
you're probably in a similar position
it's tough to get your content looking
as good as it can be without breaking
the bank or burning yourself out in the
process which is why i heavily encourage
you guys to check out what storyblocks
has to offer cheap is good do you feel
like this is their way of telling us
that the videos could be looking better
yes whether it's the credibility of an
exotic establishing shot the soothing
comfort of the perfect music bed or just
the satisfaction of increasing your
graphical capability storybox has an
incredibly inclusive and diverse library
of faces places sounds titles
transitions filters and effects and more
over a million assets royalty free and
available for personal and commercial
use with your membership sounds so
affordable this is this is quite
affordable they have multiple
subscription levels to suit your exact
needs whether you're an independent
indie solo creator or a whole team so if
you want to learn more head on down to
our link in the description box and get
started that's at storyblocks.com
rejects now back to the video thank you
again to storyblocks for uh partnering
up with us this month seriously this guy
cost a fortune a fortune a fortune every
word every year
right diet fraud
he's the only one we've hired
is great i don't know what this is a
product of that yeah i'm not as
obviously as familiar as you uh when it
comes to black adam i've read like the
shazam comics where he is the villain in
that games and seen animated movies or
black adam is he's working along with
the heroes because he has to because of
this what's at stake but i've never
actually read anything where he is just
a pure anti-hero to my understanding he
does eventually have his own run where
he is just pure anti-hero i feel like
this is only anti-hero though that i
don't get the sense of him being truly a
villain it seems like it's doing that
comic book movie thing not not quite
what sony does dude like they're going a
little bit more wrestling attitude with
it and i kind of like that kind of wish
though usually not so you get some of
these images here that uh look like they
gotta be from conduct that's like his
his domain kind of like doctor doom's
latvia yes and i think this is gonna be
i've always seen him as like a doctor
doom meets superman and that's what i
got a lot from this trailer we haven't
really seen an on-screen doctor doom
really so i think it'll be interesting
to see how audiences adjust to someone
that they don't always like the choices
that are made but you always like the
rock like his inherent charm and
charisma i think is gonna sell yeah like
there's not gonna be a moment where
you're rooting against him even if he's
doing you know unspeakable things and i
do think there's a child that pops up in
this trailer a few times with a star in
his shirt he's he's protecting him that
kid's head is the enemy no but i just
think we're gonna see him like go from
that i feel like that kid's gonna be the
reluctant okay i'm gonna help this kid
like he's gonna be like ah you're a
bother and then evolve into like
protecting and i think we're gonna see a
lot of those arcs where we're like okay
the jsa the first might be kind of
corralling him into doing things
eventually he does them on his own like
as a journey so i think the jsa is
inherently good he's inherently bad and
that kind of meets a middle ground okay
so that's why we're getting characters
like adam and hawkman yeah because like
i mean i've been wanting to see aldous
hodge as a superhero for a long time
that dude steals every movie he's in and
hawkman is a very important character
he's got his own planet there's a lot of
stuff going on with the more uh cosmic
scale of dc we're gonna see this expand
out and i think hawkman is a really
great gateway into that world into other
worldly characters because the phenar
thanegarians it's hard to say in the
morning the thanegarians are a really
noble breed of warrior that will tie
into where i think we can bring the dc
universe and making it feel bigger and
bigger and bigger and i think this is a
great start to that true i remember when
we first saw the uh black adam footage
of the little bits and they had the dc
trailer you were commenting on how it
seemed reflective of like a combination
of michael bay zack snyder the real
godly quality that snyder was trying to
capture so now that we saw a full
trailer humphrey what do you think i'm
really excited to return to the world of
the scorpion king i think this is gonna
really top the first one
no it definitely gave me that gods among
us quality that i feel like is signature
to dc especially as compared to marvel
this was an interesting blend of tones i
feel like for the first chunk of the
trailer you had this unified tone and
then you get kind of like a a joke bit
and then you get you know kind of uh you
have your action your superhero
requisite stuff but then you have some
more like psychedelic things like you
alluded to with things kind of broaching
even on dr strange imagery so i'm
excited and curious to see how they're
going to separate some of these
characters who do have similar
counterparts in other universes and just
to see what this amounts to in terms of
its relation to earth because what i got
from this trailer is a lot of godly
characters doing a lot of things here
um and i i don't know i'm curious to see
how all of that intermingles because
right now i feel like it could be could
take place kind of anywhere how does
this tie into joker two
hule vucus
clearly this is the next todd phillips
well what i think is interesting is is
you know we've had the dc universe at
large and it's been shifting and that's
actually thanks for that tangent it
sometimes feels independent with things
like joker and also sometimes feels like
it's building to a more shared universe
and also you've got characters like
aquaman and wonder woman who have done
both been a team member and been
singular this to me feels like it could
be kind of the
restart like you can really branch out
from here because you're bringing in the
first superhero team you can make their
own solo movies you've got a different
kind of first time i've ever heard that
this could be the restart
dc could go okay post flash point this
is really good timing for this jumping
on point as you're speaking of tone i
think the rock's got a very specific
kind of film where he has his humor his
action and those things and this looks
like a blend of what the dceu whether or
not they keep it that way and the rock
movies would look like combined and i
think that's a net positive for dc
building out into having like marvel
does different styles of movie like
you've got you know everybody talks
about it at nauseam guardian space opera
ant-man heist et cetera et cetera a rock
genre is very popular it's gonna do very
well and i think it's a good way to
bring people back into the fold you
already see like dc easter eggs being
planted here which is kind of why i was
speaking of the the shared universe like
the the name of the electronics store on
the truck and i do think we're gonna see
a lot of him expanding into his domain
like there's a lot you can do with the
rock being a protector that would allow
us to be like i guess he can make that
bold choice do you think the rock will
actually be somewhat of an anti-hero or
will he maintain his clean-cut
family-friendly image i mean we see
someone get murked pretty quickly in the
trailer uh we also see you know that's
about it do you think that's it
i feel like you're probably right i
think well you see him like vaporized
dude in that earlier footage we see him
like can you turn that guy to dust i
mean dc's a little more is more bold i
feel like the rock is going to push it
too like he's loved this again for over
a decade why didn't he do the accent
because
they might have tested it and that
worked like people might be so familiar
they re-shot the whole movie no but
people might be so familiar with the
rock that hearing the rock with an
accent might have turned people off like
if you if you know an actor to that
level scorpion like in the scorpion but
now like if they're it's a the rocks dc
movie i think they're leaning into the
rock you know what i mean so maybe they
don't want him to be
doing a thing other than being the rock
like that that portrayal is what they
wanted i'm guessing all i know is that
when i moved closer to you i was like we
can get these videos up faster yeah
and now knowing how much
talking has been done you've asked me
many questions i'm going to get this up
by twitter than any other video we've
ever anyone you want here we are you
know what's great it took me 11 years
for the rock to hand this out we're
going to get this out in at least 11
hours yeah that's right baby no koi
thanks for being here um yeah we were on
an all-nighter you at least got two
hours two hours of sleep so
you you carried us through again once
again we
we write on your back read some dr fake
comics i think those would be the ones
that are going to be the hardest to
really like navigate by the word
by the word
but they're great doctors someone have
told you that you can increase your
commission by advising
your bottom line
[Music]
i think it's really important
there's a door right there
[Music]